i
[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el espacio de france 24 en el
que hacemos un resumen de las noticias
más destacadas relacionadas con la
pandemia de kobe 19 soy santiago lópez
gonzález a continuación algunos de los
temas que vamos a tratar hoy vamos a
hablar de méxico este país vive una
especie de déjà vú con la tercera ola de
contagio que está viviendo las escenas
ya las vimos hace algunos meses atrás
hospitales saturados al borde del
colapso también una vacunación muy lenta
y pocas medidas de restricciones
impuestas por las autoridades
méxico ya contabiliza 2.7 millones de
casos confirmados tendremos el reporte
de ciudad de mexico en la consulta con
el doctor carlos eduardo pérez
hablaremos de varios temas entre ellos
la llamada pandemia de los que no se
están vacunando en eeuu qué
repercusiones tendrá esto en el
desarrollo de nuevas variantes en el
futuro y en el proceso de inmunización
de eeuu esto también nos lleva a otro
tema la permanencia del coronavirus y su
posible circulación endémica como tantos
otros coronavirus ya hay
en el mundo y con nuestros
corresponsales conoceremos cómo está la
situación en chile y en perú en el
primer país comenzaron ya a levantar
algunas de las restricciones ante la
leve disminución de casos de contagio
mientras que en perú hay todo un
escándalo por los pagos irregulares para
acceder a camas para atender a pacientes
que están contagiados con kobe 19
quienes se están beneficiando con estas
cuantiosas sumas de dinero se lo vamos a
contar en unos minutos pues comenzamos y
damos inicio entonces al programa con la
consulta con el doctor carlos eduardo
pérez médico infectólogo de asesor
científico de france 24 ustedes ya lo
conocen está aquí con nosotros doctor
pérez y comienzo preguntándole por
escuchando esas declaraciones del
presidente de eeuu joe biden que
calificó como una pandemia el hecho de
que miles de personas no se están
vacunando en eeuu esto entonces a
mediano y largo plazo qué consecuencias
puede traer para ese país lo digo a la
hora de lograr una inmunización
colectiva y también como beneficia esto
al coronavirus que va a seguir
circulando digámoslo
libre
esos son problemas complejos santiago
por dos razones 1 mientras haya mayor
número de contagios hay mayor
probabilidad de que haya notas varian
desayunado dirían que se vio en
california que se llama épsilon que
también es de interés y probablemente
progrese y lo segundo es que hemos visto
como estados solamente tienen un 19 20
25 por ciento de vacunación y ese esa
cobertura tan pobre a pesar de tener
toda la disponibilidad las vacunas así
que la población vulnerable se infecte y
lo que hemos visto con esta variante
delta es que es mucho más contagiosa y
va a tener una mayor presión en los
ambientes hospitalarios lamentablemente
no vacunarse es la peor decisión que
pueden tener algunas personas en este
país doctor parece es que estamos viendo
cifras muy bajas en eeuu cerca de
150.000 personas vacunándose diariamente
son cifras similares a las del mes de
enero cuando las personas apenas estaban
comenzando a conocer los procedimientos
los efectos que traían las vacunas este
país dio marcha atrás
en el número de personas vacunadas
diariamente según los reportan las
autoridades ahora me remito doctor a un
artículo que salió publicado en el
diario the washington post en el que
dice textualmente que el coronavirus
llegó para quedarse y que podría pasar
de ser una enfermedad podría pasar a ser
una enfermedad endémica como no es la
viruela el vih el sarampión y podría
pasar a ser un quinto coronavirus porque
ya tenemos 4 coronavirus que están
dispersos alrededor del mundo y con los
que convivimos y que son los causantes
de las múltiples gripes que se presentan
a lo largo del año dependiendo de las
diferentes estaciones vino para quedarse
entonces el coronavirus usted que piensa
si no tengo eso nosotros tenemos que
entender que el proceso de vacunación es
para superar la fase pandémica pero no
la eliminación del virus la eliminación
de el virus se tomará varios años cuando
hayan tratamientos efectivos y cuando la
inmunización sea colectiva es decir que
estén vacunados niños desde los 6 meses
de edad hasta las personas de 99 años y
para eso nos tomaremos un tiempo y
solamente la viruela es una enfermedad
que se ha podido eliminar con vacuna y
esta es muy probable que se tome también
una década para poderlo hacer o algo así
y lo que necesitamos ahora es frenar la
pandemia esa expansión global y eso se
hace con la vacunación pero este virus
llegó para quedarse y por eso es que
tenemos que adaptar nuestra vida y
definitivamente se va a comportar en la
población de la siguiente forma vacunado
y no vacunado quien va a enfermar el no
vacuna quien va a adaptarse a la nueva
realidad las personas que estén
inmunizadas y no hay que verlo de una
manera apocalíptica doctor como usted lo
dice tenemos que aprender a convivir con
el virus ya
ha enfrentado situaciones similares con
otras enfermedades ha hecho frente a
tanto tiempo combatirlas pero se ha
logrado salir adelante no lo demuestra
casos como el de la viruela y el
sarampión que todavía pues no están
completamente extintos pero por lo menos
si están controlados si son casos muy
específicos usted me corregirá si estas
enfermedades ya están bajo control y pos
podremos llegar a un escenario similar
en el futuro quiero preguntarle ahora
por algunos de los casos que se están
presentando en varios países algunos de
ellos de américa latina que están
teniendo problemas con las entregas de
los lotes de las vacunas y han tenido
que espaciar el tiempo de espera entre
la primera y la segunda dosis esto juega
en contra del proceso de inmunización de
los pacientes a los que se les está
demorando un poco más esa segunda dosis
pueden no tener ningún problema y no
tener ningún tipo de dificultad y
generar inmunidad hasta cierto punto
contra el coronavirus kobe 19
desde el punto de vista de la salud
pública es muy importante esa primera
dosis porque hemos visto que las
primeras dosis en grandes grupos
poblacionales hace una protección para
que no haya tantas enfermos y haya menos
colapso del sistema hospitalario sin
embargo lo ideal es cumplir con lo que
está pactado que son los tiempos que se
han acordado y donde se han hecho las
des de la vacuna realmente ahoritica y
evidencia que espaciar vacunas como la
de fires ser pues pasear vacunas como lo
que paga con si novak o con astrazéneca
hasta 12 semanas han resultado con mejor
producción de anticuerpos y digamos que
paradójicamente estos retrasos han
permitido de separar estos intervalos y
que puedan tener un mejor control
inmunológico de la enfermedad sin
embargo el mensaje es claro aquí tenemos
que vacunarnos vacunarnos es un
privilegio para cualquier persona hay
que acceder a la vacuna y hay que hacer
y que los gobiernos promuevan el
cumplimiento en las segundas dosis en el
tiempo que es si no no vamos a lograr
fácil controlar la fase pandémica que
nos demoraremos más
para pasar para poder pasar esta página
tan amarga ya vemos esa disputa que hay
entre rusia y argentina por un lote de
vacunas sputnik bay que debían haber
llegado a buenos aires para garantizar
la segunda dosis de muchos argentinos y
allí ya una disputa entre los gobiernos
porque rusia ha dicho que va a dar
prioridad a la vacunación de los rusos
antes que empezar a exportar algunas de
estas vacunas es un tema que vamos a
tratar más adelante aquí en el programa
doctor para finalizar me quedo en
argentina y precisamente le pregunto por
un estudio que fue presentado allí en
este país suramericano en el que indica
que 15.3 por ciento de los pacientes que
están hospitalizados allí en argentina
con cuadro de kobe 19 han presentado
complicaciones cardiovasculares cuando
anteriormente no tenían ningún tipo de
relación con este tipo de enfermedades
seguimos descubriendo efectos que puede
generar el kobe 19 en nuestro organismo
en este caso en particular el corazón
que es lo que le provoca al corazón el
kobe 19
si definitivamente estamos aprendiendo
esta es una enfermedad que sólo haya
solamente conocemos a casi un año y
medio sus consecuencias a mediano y
largo plazo están por escribirse y las
estamos aprendiendo qué pasa en el
corazón hay como dos a dos efectos el
primero es un efecto viral directo que
produce un daño en la estructura
cardíaca que es una inflamación y se
llama miocarditis esa inflamación del
corazón puede tener consecuencias a
mediano oa largo plazo en la funcionaria
del corazón y en otras personas que han
tenido cohetes sobre todo cerebros en
recría unidades de contención han tenido
un compromiso cardiaco de su función
cardíaca y su sistema cardiovascular a
mediano plazo por eso la mejor forma es
prevenirlo porque algunas personas dicen
yo prefiero hospitalizarme que vacunarme
o menos mal medio el problema es que
muchas personas se les da alcohol no les
va a pasar nada pero todos nos sabemos a
quién puede complicarse o tener
complicaciones a mediano oa largo plazo
como se han descrito las
cardiovasculares pero también están
descritas complicaciones neurológicas
y de otros órganos entonces
definitivamente esta es una enfermedad
que estamos aprendiendo y cada día
estamos descubriendo que hay
complicaciones más podemos tener arturo
doctor muchas gracias por esta consulta
por haber resuelto nuestras dudas y las
dudas de los televidentes aquí en kobe
19 la semana en américa como siempre un
gusto muchas gracias cambiamos de tema
méxico hace frente a la tercera ola de
contagio las escenas ya las habíamos
visto en el pasado hospitales llenos
salas de cuidados intensivos saturadas
las cifras de contagio disparadas y
lamentablemente también personas
falleciendo para el cierre de esta
semana méxico contabiliza más de 2.7
millones de casos confirmados a lo largo
de toda la emergencia sanitaria en este
país más de 237 mil personas ya han
fallecido en la república mexicana por
el coronavirus y hasta el momento más de
58 millones de dosis de vacunas ya han
sido suministradas
y vamos a conocer más detalles con
mario' carbonell en ciudad de méxico
hola mario pues ya lo estábamos diciendo
el alto número de casos que se están
registrando con motivo de esta tercera
ola a la que le está haciendo frente
méxico es muy preocupante la situación
allí que dicen las autoridades cómo está
el panorama
así es de nueva cuenta estamos en una
situación delicada el más reciente
reporte del comportamiento de la
epidemia refleja un aumento del 46 por
ciento respecto de la semana anterior de
medición este incremento acelerado de
casos se comenzó a notar desde el 20 de
julio cuando se dieron a conocer 13 mil
800 casos de contagio confirmados en el
lapso de 24 horas al día siguiente
fueron 15 1200
un día después 16 mil 200 es decir el
aumento entre un día y otro es de 1000
casos cada día y además a partir del
jueves se rompió la barrera de los 100
mil casos activos estos que son
directamente transmisores del virus por
haber presentado síntomas en las últimas
14 14 días y las pruebas de detección de
comida en los que otros públicos al
menos de la ciudad han aumentado en más
de 100 por ciento
-mario varios medios mexicanos están
reportando la saturación de los
hospitales y también de las salas de
cuidado intensivo este es el fenómeno
que traen este tipo de olas ha sido
similar en diferentes países alrededor
del mundo que medidas adicionales está
imponiendo allí las autoridades
mexicanas dependiendo del estado medidas
a nivel federal para hacer frente a esta
situación
en cuanto a la hospitalización también
ha ido en aumento aunque en mucho menor
ritmo que los contagios
estamos en 36 por ciento de ocupación en
camas generales no obstante hay
hospitales como el instituto nacional de
enfermedades respiratorias que es el más
importante del país para este tipo de
padecimientos que lleva 15 días con el
área de cuidados intensivos
prácticamente saturadas de acuerdo con
datos oficiales hay 141 hospitales con
70% de ocupación es decir prácticamente
en riesgo de saturación que están
diciendo las autoridades bueno están
haciendo un llamado por ejemplo a no
viajar en este periodo vacacional para
romper las cadenas de contagio y además
la secretaria de salud presentó un nuevo
diseño de los parámetros del semáforo
epidemiológico que responda a la nueva
dinámica de la epidemia lo que llama la
atención es que aún cuando un estado
esté en color rojo ya no habrá cierre
total de actividades esto porque según
el subsecretario de salud hugo lópez
gatell la sociedad ya está cansada está
fatigada y no puede haber un
confinamiento total como él
de la pandemia mar y lo paradójico es
que le piden a los mexicanos no viajar
pero méxico está abierto al turismo
internacional y miles de turistas
procedentes de estados unidos canadá
europa y suramérica han ido a este país
ahora con motivo del verano boreal
uno de los temas también destacados esta
semana mario allí en méxico fue la cifra
oficial que dieron a conocer del número
de niños huérfanos que ha dejado el cob
y 19 la cifra es alarmante 195 mil
menores de edad han perdido a sus padres
por haberse contagiado de kobe 19 que
dice el gobierno que van a hacer con
estos menores
vaya que ha sacudido al país esta
noticia publicada en esta revista
británica the lancet en el sentido de
que 131 mil niñas niños y adolescentes
en méxico quedaron huérfanos a raíz del
cob y lo que coloca al país como el de
mayor número de menores en situación de
orfandad se calcula que son 33.000 niños
los que perdieron a su madre y alrededor
de 98 mil los que se quedaron sin su
papá por el commit 19 y hablando
hablando de menores el presidente lópez
obrador insiste en que es una necesidad
imperiosa que los alumnos vuelvan a
clases presenciales a partir de inicios
de septiembre dice que ya no se pueden
tener a los niños encerrados en las
casas porque sufren un daño psicológico
además están expuestos dice a contenidos
tóxicos en internet y las redes sociales
sin embargo pues esta directriz no es
obligatoria de manera que pues ya
veremos ya veremos si se da esto de la
vuelta a clases presencial
mariah otra de las problemáticas que
comienza a darse a conocer con la
pandemia del cobi 19 muchas gracias por
este completo reporte desde ciudad de
mexico y la variante delta sigue
avanzando rápidamente por el mundo
gracias a su alta capacidad de contagio
también 11 países o territorios del
continente américa americano ya han
reportado casos en algunos de ellos
corresponden a personas que han viajado
al extranjero y han regresado importando
así el virus veamos el mapa del
continente americano estos son los
países que ya han alertado sobre casos
allí en sus territorios desde el extremo
norte de canadá y vamos en descenso
también eeuu bueno canadá eeuu méxico
ecuador perú chile argentina paraguay
brasil guyana y el territorio de
ultramar francés de la guyana francesa
ya han reportado casos de la variante
delta panamá ha detectado a pacientes
con la variante be punto 1.617 que tiene
origen desconocido pero que posiblemente
sean casos que están relacionados con la
variante delta otros países como por
ejemplo colombia no están haciendo
seguimiento para determinar si ya hay
de esta variante en su territorio
nos vamos ahora hasta las ciudades de
nueva york que recuerden que en un
momento álgido de la pandemia esta
ciudad de estadounidense fue el foco
mundial de la pandemia de kobe 19 allí
los trabajadores del sector de la salud
podrían ser suspendidos con el no pago
de sus salarios si se niegan a vacunarse
o a no tomarse una prueba semanal para
descartar algún tipo de contagio esto lo
que sucede veamos
ante el creciente número de casos de la
variante delta nueva york' toma medidas
vacunas o pruebas semanales para los
trabajadores de los hospitales de la
ciudad
la nueva política entrará en vigor el 2
de agosto el alcalde de la ciudad
bill de blasio dijo que cualquier
empleado que se niegue a ser inoculado
oa practicarse la prueba será suspendido
sin goce de sueldo
es hora de actuar se trata de mantener a
las personas a salvo y detener a la
variante delta la variante delta
representa el 80 por ciento de los casos
ahora estamos viendo un aumento en las
hospitalizaciones en admisiones en las
ucis y veo que es diferente son personas
más jóvenes las que están llegando a los
hospitales estamos viendo un aumento en
los niños en la unidad de cuidados
intensivos de pediatría y eso nos
preocupa por las muertes por kobe de 19
han aumentado 48 por ciento en la última
semana según los centros para el control
de enfermedades que además anunciaron
que la expectativa de vida en eeuu cayó
un año y medio en 2020 hasta 77
y cuatro meses se trata del peor
descenso desde la segunda guerra mundial
vamos a las cifras como avanzó la
pandemia de kobe 19 veamos las cifras a
nivel global para el cierre de esta
semana bueno a nivel mundial entonces ya
hay confirmados más de 192 millones 800
mil casos de kobe 19 unos 4 millones 139
mil personas han fallecido en todo el
mundo por cuenta del coronavirus y hasta
el momento han sido administradas más de
tres mil 774 millones de dosis de
vacunas alrededor del mundo
en otros temas el gobierno de argentina
ha presionado a rusia para que le sean
entregadas 18.5 millones de dosis de la
vacuna sputnik ve que están pendientes
de ser entregadas algunas de ellas para
poder garantizar esa segunda dosis de
inoculación y que ante la demora están
retrasando entonces el plan de
vacunación argentino después de este
reclamo hecho por buenos aires- moscú
respondió que enviara el lote una vez
satisfaga la demanda interna sin darle
una fecha aproximada así están las cosas
y ha sido firme con argentina primero
resolverá la demanda interna y luego
atenderá la queja del retraso de la
llegada de la segunda dosis de la vacuna
sputnik ve en la nación sudamericana es
public be fue la primera vacuna que
llegó al país austral cuando comenzó la
campaña de vacunación en diciembre pero
rusia no sacó bien los cálculos de la
segunda dosis del segundo componente
envió menos cantidades y se necesitan
ambas en igualdad para obtener
resultados de la vacuna argentina cuenta
con más de 9 millones de dosis del
componente 1 y casi 2.500.000 del
componente 2 la presión a rusia se debe
a que el país está esperando 18 5
millones de dosis para cumplir con los
requerimientos de la vacuna la
consecuencia el pasado 7 de julio el
gobierno de alberto fernández presentó
una carta formar al kremlin presionando
para el cumplimiento del pacto al punto
que amenazó con que el contrato puede
ser cancelado la insistencia de obtener
la vacuna proviene de que el país ya ha
superado las 100.000 muertes
solo 5.8 millones de argentinos han sido
completamente vacunados siendo
argentinas una de las naciones con mayor
brecha entre la administración de la
primera y segunda dosis venezuela
también tiene un déficit de la inyección
rusa pero hasta este momento se mantiene
en silencio sobre el tema
rusia atacada en este momento por la
variante delta está abocada a controlar
el virus y concentra toda la producción
de su vacuna para inocular la a su
población brevemente les cuento otras
noticias destacadas de la semana
comenzamos en uruguay noticia muy
positiva este país ya vacuno al 70% de
la población con al menos una dosis esto
refleja una leve disminución en el
número de contagios diarios y también en
el número de personas que están
hospitalizadas colombia inició esta
semana la vacunación para las personas
entre 30 y 34 años el gobierno de este
país suramericano también anunció que va
a recibir una donación de eeuu de 3.5
millones de dosis de la vacuna de la
farmacéutica moderna colombia se
convierte así en el mayor receptor de
donaciones de vacunas de
eeuu y las autoridades sanitarias de
paraguay confirmaron los seis primeros
casos de la variante delta en asunción
la capital de ese país y también en el
departamento central y está por ser
determinado si estas personas viajaron
al extranjero o si esta variante está
presentándose allí por circulación
comunitaria y vamos entonces al sur del
continente en su en chile hubo varios
anuncios y novedades importantes a lo
largo de esta semana como por ejemplo un
leve descenso en el número de los casos
también la posible apertura de las
fronteras de ese país vamos a conocer
entonces más detalles con patricia luna
en santiago nuestra corresponsal hay en
la capital chilena y patricia creo que
lo destacado esta semana entonces para
comenzar es que por fin chile estaba
comenzando a mostrar una disminución en
los casos a nivel nacional durante mucho
tiempo tuvo un sostenido repunte de
contagios en las hospitalizaciones y
también repuntes en el número de
contagios que no daban tregua claramente
al panorama de este país y ya pues
parece que todo comienza a cambiar cómo
están las cosas
hola santiago chile vive unos momentos
de tranquilidad en medio de la pandemia
así lo confirma el último informe y kobe
publicado en conjunto por la universidad
de chile universidad católica y
universidad de concepción que confirma
que esta semana la tasa de contagios con
100 mil habitantes estuvo por primera
vez en lo que va de año por debajo del
0,8 por ciento y confirma siendo
descenso sostenido de siete semanas en
el número de casos desde que se produjo
una de las cifras más altas el 31 de
mayo pasado también el ministerio de
salud
esta semana déjela el número de
contagios había descendido en un 33 en
los últimos siete días y hasta un 45% en
los últimos 14 días también se ha
producido un descenso en la mortalidad
hasta un 22% en los últimos 7 días según
las autoridades y también el
subsecretario de redes asistenciales
alberto doña informaba que el número de
personas que ingresan de manera diaria a
las unidades de cuidados intensivos es
de 74 personas 70 personas menos que
durante la primera ola y 156 personas
menos que durante la segunda ola un
momento por tanto en el que se
consolidan las cifras bajas en chile-
cifras alentadoras patricia y también es
destacado y también es una buena noticia
para este país que las autoridades
dieron el visto bueno para el uso de
emergencia de la vacuna rusa sputnik ve
en ese país suramericano
el miércoles de esta semana el instituto
de salud pública aprobaba el uso de
emergencia de una sexta vacuna en chile
se trata de las 5 la vacuna del
instituto ruso gama leia que ya se
aplica en 70 países entre ellos
argentina y méxico ellis el director del
instituto de salud pública de heriberto
garcía confirmaba la aprobación de esta
vacuna para una población mayor de 18
años y sin rango de edad superior y
explicaba que se trata de una vacuna que
tiene dos componentes una primer
componente sería similar a la vacuna
jansen y un segundo componente similar a
la vacuna cansino ambas aprobadas en
chiles son 6 las vacunas que ya existen
en el país en la primera en aprobación
fue el kaiser después
sinovac astrazéneca yangtsé cansino
ahora es wikileaks de la que se espera
que lleguen aproximadamente 3 y 4
millones de dosis en los próximos meses
chile y ha recibido 27 millones de dosis
de distintas vacunas y se administran
todas las vacunas que han sido aprobadas
a la selección de janssen de la que no
se ha recibido todavía suministro sexta
vacuna que llega a reforzar ese plan de
vacunación en chile patricia y seguimos
con las buenas noticias debido a este
buen escenario que se está
en chile las autoridades ya han
considerado levantar algunas de las
restricciones incluso unas de las más
rígidas como por ejemplo el cierre de
las fronteras
la región metropolitana entera entraba
en fase tres de las cuatro que existen
en el plan paso a paso del gobierno
chileno que se fue reformulado
recientemente esta tercera fase en la
que se encuentra a toda la región
metropolitana permite la apertura de
gimnasios de cines de teatros de
espectáculos de distinto tipo y empieza
a hacerse una distinción entre aquellas
personas que ya han completado su
sistema de inoculación y cuentan con el
pase de movilidad del gobierno y
aquellas que no ven chile ya se ha
vacunado un 86% de la población objetivo
de 15 2 millones de personas y sobre los
19 millones de chilenos con una sola
dosis y un 78 por ciento de esa
población objetivo y ha completado su
sistema de inoculación con las 2 dosis
son estos los que tienen el pase de
movilidad concedido por el gobierno 15
días después de la segunda dosis y que
le permite una serie de privilegios
entre ellos los confirmados el jueves
que permitirán a los chilenos y
residentes viajar fuera del país las
autoridades señalan que para ello será
necesario un pcr negativo someterse a
los distintos test y nos recomienda
viajar porque uno podría contagiarse
de las variantes de preocupación que
existen fuera sin embargo si será
posible a partir de este lunes esta
medida ha suscitado la reacción
contraria del colegio médico que señala
que hay una alta posibilidad de que se
vuelva a ingresar una variante y surjan
rebrotes y que en este momento que chile
tiene ya controlada la pandemia hay que
mantener las fronteras cerradas para
evitar rebrotes
hay que seguir cuidándose patricia sin
embargo esto representa un respiro para
los chilenos que la han pasado mal con
la pandemia de kobe 19 al igual que el
resto de las personas alrededor del
mundo muchas gracias patricia por este
reporte desde la capital chilena y bueno
a la vacunación también sigue avanzando
en algunos países un poco más rápido que
en otros demos un vistazo al porcentaje
de población inoculada con el esquema de
vacunación ya completo en la región de
norteamérica es decir canadá méxico y
eeuu ya 136 punto 39 por ciento de la
población está vacunada con el esquema
completo en suramérica solamente el 17
puntos 57 por ciento veamos entonces
algunos países de la región colombia ya
alcanza el 21 punto 40 por ciento de la
población que tiene allí
completo que puede ser de una dosis o de
dos dosis dependiendo del tipo de vacuna
en ecuador el 11 punto 16 por ciento de
la población mientras que brasil del
gigante suramericano alcanza ya el 17.30
por ciento de la población con esquema
completo de vacunas
y miren esto en perú ha estallado un
nuevo escándalo ya tuvimos hace unos
meses el escándalo de las vacunas vip y
ahora salió a la luz la venta y pago
irregular para acceder a camas en un
hospital para ser atendido contra el
kobe 19 vamos a conocer más detalles
allí en lima con francisco zacarías se
nos va a dar más información sobre este
escándalo y también sobre otros temas
destacados a lo largo de esta semana
hola francisco gracias por acompañarnos
en el programa y bueno tenemos que
comenzar por este escándalo que
información hay al respecto ya que se
trata todo este escándalo mediático hay
en perú
santiago la justicia peruana ha
dispuesto la detención preliminar por
siete días para los integrantes de una
red criminal denominada los ángeles
negros quienes cobraban más de veinte
mil dólares por cada enfermo grave con
kobe 19 que requería una cama y la
unidad de cuidados intensivos del
hospital guillermo almenara nueve
personas entre funcionarios de salud
miembros de un organismo no
gubernamental y hasta una ex
voleibolista fueron detenidos por la
policía que ejecuta un megaoperativo en
cuatro distritos en lima la
investigación se inició en marzo de este
año gracias a la denuncia de un
ciudadano quien se quejaban de las
autoridades que le exigían dinero para
colocar a su familiar en el primer lugar
de una lista de espera de camas de
cuidados intensivos la fiscalía cree que
habrían más profesionales de salud
involucrados los detenidos podrían
cumplir una condena de cuatro a seis
años de cárcel por el delito de tráfico
de influencias por su parte el
presidente francisco sagasti ha
calificado de miserables a los
responsables de este escándalo y ha
asegurado que sobre ellos se actuará con
todo el rigor de la ley
estamos comenzando a francisco solamente
fue dado a conocer el escándalo vamos a
ver qué autoridades y que otras personas
están aquí implicadas a medida que la
investigación avance al igual que chile
perú también le dio el aval a la vacuna
rusa sputnik para ser distribuida allí y
las autoridades en lima ya cerraron un
contrato con las autoridades rusas
el gobierno peruano anunció la firma de
un contrato con la subsidiaria del fondo
ruso de inversiones directas para la
compra de 20 millones de dosis de
vacunas sputnik
contra el coi 19 que permitirán
inmunizar a 10 millones de personas las
autoridades revelaron que las
negociaciones con los representantes del
laboratorio gama leia fueron muy
prolongadas y tras varios meses de
conversaciones se firmó el acuerdo
oscar ugarte ministro de salud de este
país informó que para septiembre se
espera la primera entrega de 5 millones
de vacunas el segundo envío de 5
millones de arribar ya en octubre el
tercero durante noviembre y el último en
diciembre el gobierno peruano confía en
que los medicamentos rusos le permitirán
defender a su población ante una tercera
ola de la pandemia el coronavirus el
presidente de francisco sagasti ha
señalado que su administración tiene
acuerdos firmados para la compra de 78.7
millones de dosis de vacunas que
garantizarán un abastecimiento hasta
enero del próximo año bueno pues hoy lo
tienen 10 millones de peruanos que se
van a beneficiar con esta compra de la
vacuna sputnik hablemos del panorama
general francisco cómo está el río
de contagio las personas hospitalizadas
los fallecidos los vacunados hablemos de
números
pero registra más de 2 millones de casos
confirmados y en más de 195 mil
fallecidos por kobe 19 mientras tanto
más de 7 millones de ciudadanos ya
recibieron su primera dosis contra el
coronavirus y otros más de 4 millones de
personas
fueron inmunizadas con la segunda dosis
las autoridades de salud consideran que
el perú está en mejor posición para
afrontar una tercera ola de la pandemia
porque señalan que el sistema sanitario
se encuentra fortalecido con más camas
en unidades de cuidados intensivos así
como equipamiento y oxígeno pero
reconocen que la variante desde el
coronavirus y población sin vacunar
perfilan los riesgos de la temible
tercera ola el ministerio de salud
reveló que se han detectado 15 casos de
la variable delta en el país mientras
tanto la anda sigue predominando con un
70 y 1.6 por ciento de casos le sigue la
variante de gamma con 14.1 por ciento y
en menor proporción en la variante alfa
los actuales funcionarios le recomiendan
al nuevo gobierno de pedro castillo no
descuidar la atención de la pandemia
francisco muchas gracias por este
completo reporte desde la ciudad
a continuación demos un vistazo a otros
temas comentados en la red sobre la
pandemia de kobe 19 ya que estamos en
temporada de juegos olímpicos' guinea
renuncia a participar en los olímpicos
de tokio por el kobe 19 este país de
áfrica occidental anunció que con el
ánimo de preservar la salud de sus
atletas decidió cancelar la
participación en estas justas olímpicas
pese a que algunos de los deportistas ya
estaban en tokio y se les pidió volar de
regreso a conakry la capital de guinea
es la tercera vez que guinea suspende su
participación ya sucedió en múnich 72 y
en montreal 76 también destacado en
redes cubas realizará un ensayo con una
vacuna anti kobe en embarazadas y
lactantes se trata de un estudio de
intervención sanitaria que inocula dos
dosis de la vacuna soberana 2 y una
dosis de refuerzo de la vacuna soberana
plus a unas 9000 mil mujeres en
residentes de la ciudad de la habana la
capital de cuba la controversia radica
en que ninguna de estas dos vacunas ha
recibido autorización para su uso de
emergencia por parte del ente regulador
cubano
y en france24 punto com encontramos este
artículo china rechaza una segunda
investigación de la o ms sobre el origen
del virus la organización mundial de la
salud de buscaría investigar en esta
oportunidad en algunos laboratorios
locales y mercados para determinar el
origen del virus el gobierno de beijing
consideró que es una investigación
arrogante y politizada
es todo aquí en kobe 19 la semana en
américa no se encontraban la próxima
semana con más noticias destacadas de la
pandemia a lo largo y ancho de nuestro
continente sigan cuidando se laven las
manos un tapabocas y sigan viendo
france24